I turned a bison patty around and
suddenly I've seen this sparkling
emerald under the bison patty and I
didn't expect it if you find a horny
beetle it's always a male the rainbow
scarabs are amongst the most beautiful
of beetles they are not the largest but
if you see that shiny exoskeleton these
green emerald shiny beetle in the
sunlight it's just so amazing that a
beetle that lives in poop all of its
life is so pretty the dung beetle fauna
in Colorado is very poor is impoverished
so in the old times we had 60 million
bison on the Great Plains they were
eradicated in the late 1800s when we had
60 million bison they pooped over 600
million times a day 365 days a year that
was a lot of poop so there were
certainly a lot of dung beetles a rich
dung beetle fauna now well if you go out
there and look under a bison paddy you
should do that just take one turn it
around you see there are very few dung
beetles oh here's a wonderful fresh
piece of bison poop out here with within
a dry area with a lot of wind the poop
builds a crust almost immediately
like this what do you see so you can
touch it with your finger and the finger
is still clean because it's dry lots of
people don't think about that a small
group of insects have a serious effect
on our environment or on their
livelihood but they do they're very
efficient recycles of dung of and if you
have lots of those beetles that is a
wonderful way to maintain soil quality
because you want to have a fertile soil
in the natural grassland it's very
tedious actually to pick all the dung
beetles out in the field
so what we do we collect the dung in a
bucket take it home and float it the
dung sinks to the ground but all the
beetles float on top and it's just
interesting all these brown ones that
I'm collecting right now they haven't
been in Colorado 20 years ago it just
came in in the last 10-15 years and now
they are everywhere and probably the
most common species of dung beetles in
the state the rainbow scarab beetle is
very rare we found probably 15 to 20
amongst 80 thousand specimens we found
in the last eight years in our bison
beetle project what we want to study is
if you bring a bison herd back into an
area and we started that eight years ago
when a small bison herd was brought to
Plains Conservation Center site does
this have an effect on a on the dung
beetle fauna does it regenerate who the
native dung beetles become more abundant
during these eight years they had about
40 bison on the side now they have it
changed to over 300 350 bison and we
will see if that changes the dung beetle
fauna more dramatically I've never found
anybody who was not fascinated by these
beetles until I told them that's a dung
beetle
and they were well a little bit
irritated because people think dung
beetles are ugly and little and brown
and stinky and that is a wonderful
pretty jewel of a beetle
[Music]